buon pomeriggio a tutti un buon
pomeriggio diventa ciò che sei
perché ho scelto questo titolo che qual
è il collegamento con gli umani e
connessioni quando mi hanno invitato mi
hanno mi hanno chiesto il titolo detto
diventa ciò che sei dice sì ma stiamo
parlando di una le connessioni sì non
c'è niente di più importante che
ritornare ad essere quello che eravamo
proprio per utilizzare al meglio la
tecnologia ed è da qui che dobbiamo
ripartire
io mi occupo come avete sentito di
coaching adolescenziale sono life and
mental coach
il lavoro con gli adolescenti e tenete
presente che l'adolescenza va dagli 11
ai 27 anni è una bella forbice e
parallelamente lavoro con i genitori per
lavorare sull'adolescente dobbiamo
lavorare su sul genitore e dobbiamo
farlo in fretta e sono veramente fiera
sono veramente onorata e anche un onere
a perché sono l'unica donna ma di essere
qui perché dobbiamo fare in fretta
perché l'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità ha detto che per il 2030 la
malattia più diffusa sarà la depressione
e la solitudine e allora che cosa
dobbiamo fare cosa dobbiamo aspettare
soprattutto noi qui che viviamo in
italia non ce lo possiamo permettere
abbiamo il sole ma abbiamo il mare
noi non possiamo assolutamente
permetterci la solitudine e anche perché
uno studio americano ha detto che le
persone di tutte le fasce d'età in entro
i primi cinque minuti dal risveglio
guardano il telefono e lo fanno circa
150 volte al giorno
ecco io non sono qui a dire di non
utilizzare gli strumenti per carità mai
non lo farò mai perché la tecnologia ci
ha aiutato assolutamente ci ha portato
tanti vantaggi ma sono qui per aiutarvi
e spero di essere una fonte di
ispirazione stasera in modo tale che
quando uscirete da qui potrete già
utilizzare qualche suggerimento che
andrò a darvi i vantaggi della top della
tecnologia non dobbiamo dimenticarlo
assolutamente l'efficienza per le
aziende
tante nuove opportunità di lavoro la
globalizzazione ci ha migliorato le
comunicazioni noi attraverso skype
possiamo collegarci con l'altra parte
del mondo senza viaggiare questo non lo
dobbiamo dimenticare però non dobbiamo
nemmeno dimenticare questo che noi siamo
come gli animali gli esseri umani hanno
bisogno di cercare di vivere con i
propri simili
ed è questo che ci porterà la tristezza
e la solitudine se non facciamo in
fretta e se non lavoriamo su di noi
perché per istinto naturale dobbiamo
stare con i nostri simili perché ci dà
sicurezza ma soprattutto perché ci fa
stare bene e io stasera proprio di
questo che vi voglio parlare cos'è che
ci fa stare bene che cos'è che ci manca
perché noi siamo quello come vi dicevo
che c'è stato dato nei primi 1000 giorni
di vita e poi dai 3 ai 7 anni
noi siamo questo siamo il tutto ciò che
c'è stato donato nei primi anni e poi
tutto ad un tratto con l'adolescenza
tutto questo va a scomparire ed è
proprio qui il problema ed è proprio qui
che vi poi di portare a riflettere
partendo da questo ma come stiamo
utilizzando il nostro tempo ed è proprio
questo se il dispositivo se il cellulare
se lo se il computer sta rubando il
nostro tempo il tempo è la cosa più
preziosa che noi abbiamo
e allora dobbiamo utilizzarlo al meglio
altrimenti ci porta la frustrazione e
allora da dove quale domanda vi farò per
prima quali sono i tuoi valori quali
sono i vostri valori come stai
utilizzando il tuo tempo quali sono le
tue priorità noi dobbiamo ripartire da
qua
e allora sono felice di condividere con
voi con questa comunità la mia idea
perché questo che dobbiamo diffondere
perché troppi di noi che hanno dei figli
adolescenti trascorrono troppo tempo
dietro al cellulare molto meno al valore
della della famiglia e del giovane che
sta crescendo
ed eccoci noi siamo noi siamo quello che
c'è stato dato tra zero e tre anni poi
vi ho detto
37 anni e la nostra autostima fino a 10
anni che ci crea che ci regala il regalo
più bello che un educatore possa fare è
una sana autostima come come avviene una
sana autostima attraverso le parole
quelle convinzioni potenzianti che molto
spesso invece diventano limitanti perché
quelle potenzianti se tu sei bravo è un
dovere è normale e non te lo devo fare
il complimento
e invece quando sbagli che te lo faccio
notare ed è proprio lì che sbagliamo tra
0 e 3 anni pensate i miei primi 1000
giorni di vita noi formiamo i nostri
sensi
noi formiamo l'apparato psichico lì all
est e il super io il conscio il pre
conscio e l'inconscio e pensate che l'io
ha una capacità solo del 5 per cento
nella decisione il 95 per cento viene
gestito dall inconscio quelli inconscio
pensate che si basa su quelle
convinzioni limitanti su quei solchi che
noi definiamo su quelle sinapsi negative
che si sono formate nei primi anni di
vita
e allora noi dobbiamo ripartire proprio
da lì da quello che abbiamo abbandonato
da quello che abbiamo lasciato se noi
vogliamo riutilizza utilizzare scusato
utilizzare al meglio la tecnologia
perché ci ha cambiato il mondo davvero
ma non dobbiamo far cambiare noi questo
non glielo dobbiamo permettere perché
stiamo male perché dobbiamo riprendere
in mano la nostra vita proprio da qui
ecco da quello che diceva hillman
psicologo americano ogni individuo fin
da bambino proprio come una piccola
ghianda racchiude in sé tutte le
potenzialità per diventare un maestoso
albero di quercia è da qui che dobbiamo
partire perché tra 0 e 7 anni
si formano ci regalano ci donano anche
le nostre potenzialità quelle
potenzialità che poi con l'adolescenza
vengono schiacciate con l'adolescenza
che cosa accade nel cervello dei nostri
adolescenti a meraviglioso c'è un
meraviglioso processo di mieli d'azione
che nelle femmine avviene 11 anni e nei
maschi a 15
è il periodo migliore di accelerazione
noi chiamiamo nel cervello di un ragazzo
invece che cosa avviene in quel periodo
il conflitto perché l'adolescenza come
si manifesta con il conflitto con la
famiglia e con le istituzioni in questo
caso la scuola
e allora sono qui a parlare vedo gli
adulti vedo pochi adolescenti
e allora il pensiero il mio pensiero
quello che voglio far passare proprio
questo dobbiamo partire noi da un lavoro
su noi stessi per aiutare i nostri
adolescenti noi abbiamo il dovere
siamo responsabili del futuro dei nostri
ragazzi ma soprattutto siamo
responsabili dell'utilizzo di questi
strumenti perché noi per primi dobbiamo
utilizzarle al meglio e guardate quali
sono
cosa abbiamo cosa hanno i nostri figli
ognuno di noi sa se virtù coraggio
umanità temperanza trascendenza saggezza
giustizia guardate quante potenzialità e
se voi vedete ci sono delle potenzialità
nella trascendenza che sono capacità di
apprezzare la bellezza è questo qui la
capacità di apprezzare la bellezza vi
assicuro che di adolescenti che hanno
questa potenzialità ne vedo tantissimi e
purtroppo non allenano una potenzialità
depotenziata fa star male fa soffrire
porta disturbi somatoformi e gli
adolescenti lo possono manifestare in
tutte le forme e poi nella saggezza la
virtù della saggezza alla creatività
alla curiosità e allora la capacità di
apprezzare la bellezza non la possiamo
allenare
dietro ad un computer noi dobbiamo
ripartire da noi dal vivere la bellezza
dal video e la bellezza della natura dal
vivere la realtà e dal vivere la realtà
attraverso i cinque sensi
da qui dobbiamo ripartire perché allora
possiamo si vivere le emozioni emozioni
positive perché le emozioni sono 54 sono
negative tristezza paura rabbia disgusto
solo uno è positiva la felicità e la
gioia e sapete che cosa diceva daniel
coleman il genitore noi gli educatori
dobbiamo occuparci e preoccuparci
dell'intelligenza emotiva l'emotività le
emozioni e se noi viviamo costantemente
nella rabbia perché non utilizziamo al
meglio i nostri strumenti tecnologici
perché magari non siamo nati nell'era
del digitale
veniamo da un l'eroe dell'analogico e
quindi siamo entrati in corsa nel
digitale
ecco qua che ci troviamo in difficoltà
lo utilizziamo al peggio e facciamo
vivere le nostre emozioni ai nostri
ragazzi
è da qui che dobbiamo ripartire perché a
volte nel virtuale sapete cosa ci
mettiamo dietro a quelle immagini dietro
la virtualità
sapete cosa c'è c'è quello ideale quello
che noi vorremmo essere
e quando e viviamo quella dicotomia tra
quelli o ideale e ritorniamo nella
realtà ed è lì che stiamo male ed è lì
che non vorremmo stare e allora che cosa
si manifesta tutta la rabbia e allora
tutte quelle emozioni negative emergono
tutte e come le vivono i ragazzi che ci
stanno accanto come li facciamo vivere
così loro vivono le nostre emozioni
noi la società è lo specchio parlante
dell'adolescente e allora abbiamo una
grande responsabilità sulle mozioni e
allora come vivere la realtà come
fargliela vivere
ecco qui voglio fare proprio un
passaggio importante ascoltatemi
veramente attentamente perché tutto qui
il nostro benessere
abbiamo sentito parlare del qui ed ora
ma come lo viviamo il qui ed ora lo
viviamo attraverso la felicità
ma qual è la felicità quando faccio
questa domanda mi dicono sì la felicità
non esiste sì esiste la felicità esiste
da individuale e parte da noi e se
vogliamo insegnare ai nostri figli i
nostri ragazzi dobbiamo viverla noi per
primo è come la viviamo attraverso i
cinque sensi e perché sono quei cinque
sensi che ci sono stati regalati dai
nostri educatori il senso visivo il
senso di tivo e il senso cinestesico 82
per cento di noi e visivo e come vive la
realtà attraverso attraverso le immagini
ma visivo vede la realtà diverso da un
additivo perché il visivo e quello che
ti guarda in faccia e quello che la
realtà la vive appieno si emoziona per
nel vedere un tramonto e si emoziona nel
vedere un alba si emoziona nel fare
delle fotografie
l'obiettivo è totalmente diverso
l'obiettivo è perché è diventato di tivo
perché tra 0 e 3 anni zero sette anni
degli educatori hanno stimolato il senso
di tivo leggendo le favole facendo
ascoltare la musica e poi però qual è la
caratteristica che sono ragazzi siamo
siamo diversi dagli alti piccolo 18 per
cento questo le persone uditive che però
hanno caratteristiche diverse
quando parlano tendenzialmente non ti
guardano negli occhi perché pongono
l'orecchio sono disordinate quando sono
a scuola magari disegnano fanno altro ma
sono di un intelligenza stratosferica
anno è stato studiato che hanno un
quoziente intellettivo del 139 per cento
eppure si trovano in difficoltà e vivono
la realtà attraverso la musica
ascoltando la musica e poi c'è il senso
cinestesico il cinestesico chi è è il
primo tra l'altro il cinestesico e tatto
gusto e olfatto il tatto il primo senso
che alleniamo è quel senso che alleniamo
toccando la pelle di nostra madre
il secondo senso il gusto e il terzo
senso è l'olfatto sono delle persone
profonde che si emozionano guardando un
film ci emozioniamo ascoltando una
musica e ci emozioniamo accarezzando la
pelle facendo un abbraccio ricevendo un
abbraccio
sono quei ragazzi che amano gli abbracci
e le coccole e allora capite che la
tecnologia ci aiuta ci ha aiutato ci
sarà tanti vantaggi ma cosa ci manca
ci manca tutto questo ci manca allenare
i nostri cinque sensi
i nostri cinque sensi che ci portano
sapete dove ad allenare i due cervelli
il cervello del corpo perché poi andiamo
a mettere in circolo endorfine e il
cervello dell'addome che mette in
circolo serotonina e dopamina e se
questo non lo facciamo guardate cosa c'è
in circolo dentro il nostro corpo che
produce ancora rabbia il cortisolo il
cortisolo che ci porta ad avere effetti
delle pressioni per tensione ma
soprattutto quello che a me interessa in
questo momento
l'ostilità e molto spesso dove la
trasmettiamo questa ostilità facciamo
presto con un click con un messaggio con
un messaggio sbagliato ed è questo che
deve passare noi dobbiamo allenare i
nostri due cervelli attivando i nostri
neurotrasmettitori
e voi capite che tutto questo dietro un
computer dietro un cellulare non c'è e
allora bene utilizziamo cellulare del
computer ma è altrettanto vero che noi
dobbiamo allenare i nostri sensi perché
allora sì che ci porta alle unioni sa
che cos'è la felicità
dell'autorealizzazione far girare quella
ruota della vita che è formata da tre
aree l'area delle relazioni l'area
dell'autonomia e l'area delle competenze
come va con le mie relazioni come va con
il mio lavoro con la mia indipendenza
economica
sono soddisfatto delle mie competenze ho
fatto gli studi che volevo fare
oppure vorrei cambiare tutto ecco
e allora sì che possiamo arrivare alla
felicità e voi capite che tutto questo
però dietro a un oggetto come il
computer come il cellulare non l'abbiamo
e allora dobbiamo riattivarlo perché
siamo riattivare la nostra felicità
quella del fare quella dell'essere e
quella della mare qual è la felicità del
fare è riprendere quelle attività
riprendere a fare quelle attività che
facevamo quando eravamo piccoli che cosa
facevamo con i nostri educatori che cosa
ci facevano fare quali era un'attività
che ci piacevano di più soprattutto
manuali quelle attività che se li
facciamo ora ci portano al senso della
distorsione del pala di distorsione del
senso del tempo sono quelle attività che
ci portano in quello definito stato di
flow di totale benessere e capite che
tutto questo non c'è dietro la
tecnologia allora dobbiamo riattivarlo
noi per farlo vivere i nostri
adolescenti poi c'è la felicità
dell'essere la felicità dell'essere e
attivare tutti e cinque sensi e allora
ecco la bellezza di andare al mare di
guardare il mare di emozionarsi
guardandolo e fotografandolo anche
magari e di registrare il rumore del
mare e di sentire il profumo del mare di
sentire la sabbia e di sentire i sapori
tutti e cinque i sensi ci servono per
vivere la nostra felicità la felicità
dell'essere poi c'è la felicità della
mare e quale è quella di donarsi agli
altri di stare con gli altri tanti
ragazzi tanti di noi stanno bene a
stanno bene quando donano quando si
sentono di fare volontariato di aiutare
gli altri
ecco tutto questo dietro la tecnologia
dietro un cellulare o dietro un computer
viene a mancare e come vi ho detto
all'inizio non possiamo permettere che
la depressione e la solitudine prende il
sopravvento
e allora sono felice di avervi di poter
essere stata spero fonte d'ispirazione
questa sera perché possiate attraverso
quello che avete ascoltato creare
un'onda perché qui dobbiamo creare
un'onda
ed aiutare i nostri giovani i nostri
adolescenti e tutti noi insieme per
poter vivere questa realtà in modo più
sereno e vivere si il qui ed ora grazie
[Applauso]